I have no choice but to start today with
the Brazen and immoral not just
willingness but desire to hurt Americans
from the newly in control of the House
of Representatives Republican party
because they believe it will help them
in 2024. yesterday I told you about a
post that the failed former president
Donald Trump made to his social media
platform truth social truth essential
and to review that post let's just put
it up on the screen where Donald Trump
said in all capital letters quote
Republicans can get almost everything
back that the old broken Crow Mitch
McConnell and the real leader
china-centric Coco Chao stupidly gave up
to the Democrats over the last two years
by simply playing tough in the upcoming
debt ceiling negotiations with the right
negotiators like all of those involved
the other night on both sides for
speaker it will be a beautiful and
joyous thing for the people of our
country to watch make America great
again now you sometimes have to read
between the lines when Trump speaks
because it does it's not even clear he
knows what he's saying in this case he
does know what he's saying he is saying
shut down the government over the debt
ceiling damage the country which will
then show people how much they want
Republicans in power and they will vote
for us in 2024. now it was not just
Donald Trump who became willing to say
this over the last 24 hours we have
countless more examples now and I'm
going to look at a couple first and
foremost last night
Sean Hannity Fox News propagand this
hosted some kind of a sort of town hall
type event with the new Speaker of the
House Kevin McCarthy and here is Sean
Hannity suggesting to Kevin McCarthy
shut down the government
shut down the government when it comes
down to the debt ceiling debate take a
listen by the way what they did in the
Senate I believe as a conservative that
was a disgrace yeah I think and they
knew you were coming into power and they
knew they could why wouldn't they just
wait if they waited then we'd have a
stronger hand exactly we wouldn't be
increasing it and they increased the
Baseline where it just adds so much more
to our children let's talk about a
moment maybe it comes sooner maybe it
comes later on the debts ceiling and you
know how the argument will unfold it'll
be Republicans are shutting down
government I've been around this game
too long government never shuts down
essential services will exist Grandma
Mom and Dad they're going to get their
social security check Medicare is not
going to be shut down the military is
not going to be shut down now there
might be people that get furloughed ah
but odds are pretty high that when they
get their free vacation they they will
get back pay
but that will be the argument yeah so
Hannity likes the idea here of the
government shutdown now the question
will be it'll become a game of chicken
and that is Republicans are shutting
down the government and they're not
willing to raise the debt ceiling and
you're going to say what well listen it
doesn't have to come to that I've
already spoken to the president let's
sit down now yeah so Hannity likes the
idea and he says they'll say it's bad
for the country when the government when
the government is shut down but it's not
really that bad for the country now I
disagree with that and I'm going to
explain that to you in a moment here's
another example new Republican
congresswoman Anna Paulina Luna she says
she's also willing to support a shutdown
of the government oh I just stand by
because it's going to be a wild week
well you know some of your moderate
members within the Republican party as
I'm sure you know say that's a dangerous
thing because it sets up almost a
guaranteed government shutdown
um and that because spending has been
tied to renegotiating the debt limit or
extending it it's inevitable do you
think it's inevitable that we'll be
looking at a shutdown because of some of
these measures that the speaker agreed
to
um I hope it doesn't get to that but I'm
willing to support one and I do think
that the speaker made the correct
decision in ensuring that we do cut
again some of this pork Runway inflation
and spending and so she's willing to
support a government shutdown now of
course there's two sides to this the
first side of it is that for many of
these Republicans the government being
shut down is a feature not a bug in the
sense that as I've told you many times
before many of these right Wingers want
government doing as little as possible
and so for them when they say oh the
government shut down that's great as
much as we can take off of the list of
things that government is doing that's a
good thing now often they can't come out
and publicly say that but privately many
of them love government shutdown because
they don't want the government doing
stuff they still want their paychecks by
the way but they don't want government
doing stuff but it is not true
that when the government is shut down
over the debt ceiling it doesn't impact
anything now in a sense yes in the
immediate people continue to get Social
Security checks but when the government
shuts down essential government services
stop being funded that does include
Social Security and Medicare now in the
immediate people still get their checks
but it is not indefinitely true and so
the idea that it has no impact is of
course a lie it can also lead to a
Slowdown in the economy when the
government shuts down government
contracts government purchases are put
on hold government employees are
furloughed sometimes they get back pay
sometimes they don't it can cause job
losses and financial difficulties for
the government workers but also for the
private sector businesses that rely on
government spending now again some of
these Republicans love that some of
these Republicans think we the
government shouldn't do deals with
private businesses the government
shouldn't be to be spending the
government shouldn't be doing the
government should be shut down that's
their default that's very extreme
we're talking about those in the middle
who say well I want the government open
in principle but it's not that bad if
it's shut down it really can be very
very bad it raises the risk of a debt
default which can have more than dire
consequences uh a default can lead to an
increase in interest rates and that
makes it more expensive for the
government to borrow money for
individuals and businesses to borrow
money as a result of that all of these
things when they say there's no negative
impact what I think they're saying is if
we contrive this deliberately but it
only lasts a little while we will reopen
after we've made our political point
before things get too bad but that's an
extraordinarily cynical approach to how
you do politics and
um the truth is that a government
shutdown is bad for the American people
in all sorts of different ways it's
irresponsible it's Reckless and they are
willing to do it they don't have
principles or at least the principles
they have are very different than the
ones they publicly State a real Prince
principle for the 2023 Republican party
or House Republicans we could say
is let's do whatever we think is best
for us politically over the next couple
of years that's a real principle the
principles they'll state are were for
small government conservatism and
freedom and liberty and the Constitution
and supporting law enforcement and
every single one of those we've seen
abandoned when they're no longer
convenient the real principle that they
pledge allegiance to on in an unwavering
fashion is one they won't say out loud
we will do whatever it takes to try to
make Democrats look bad
and to try to help ourselves for our own
re-elections and whatever the next
election cycle is they're making it very
clear they're saying it openly and by
the way they're also now talking about
diversity while in a room full of white
people emblematic of what the Republican
party is I want to talk about that next
did you know that half of Americans are
deficient in vitamin A vitamin C and
magnesium most Americans are deficient
in vitamin D I take vitamin D during the
winter it is sometimes difficult to eat
exactly the right amount of each food to
get exactly what you need I just make my
life simpler with ag1 by athletic Greens
in the morning one scoop of ag1 I get
the entire day's worth of 75 high
quality vitamins minerals and Whole Food
sourced ingredients it's what I want
it's no more it's no less it's not
making any outlandish claims it's just
an easy sustainable routine I've tried
different ways of taking vitamins ag1 is
cheaper it's quicker it's tastier I'm
not fumbling around with different
capsules it tastes great to drink
straight with water sometimes I'll put
it in a smoothie or Shake it's simple
it's something easy you can do going
into the new year staying properly
nourished athletic greens is giving my
audience a free year supply of vitamin D
I take that every day in Winter plus
you'll get five free travel packs of ag1
go to athleticgreens.com
Pacman the link is down below